welcome back some of china's live fire
exercises around taiwan have concluded
five days after u.s speaker nancy pelosi
ignited a spat by visiting the island
but this afternoon chinese state
television report that the military will
conduct regular drills near taiwan from
now on
further heightening tensions well let's
explore what's happening on the ground
now with retired uh vice marshal sean
bell
so um sean it's great to um have you
here i mean looking at this now
obviously we see that the military
exercises have come to an end
what do we know
yeah i mean it's day four of the biggest
single military um exercise in the
region ever massive show of force we've
had over 100 chinese faster aircraft and
bombers involved over 10 um chinese
warship involved most significantly 11
ballistic missiles fired that have
landed all the way around the island of
taiwan um they've also all of this has
been conducted in really close proximity
to the island itself certainly within
the territorial waters which obviously
carries grave risks to the civilian
lives there but also the risk of
miscalculation bluntly if something goes
wrong and then it gets escalation the
positive the exercise has concluded and
it hasn't escalated but as you're
reporting the chinese are saying that
they're going to be doing these sorts of
drills more regularly in the future so
what will china then have gained from
these drills and crucially what lessons
is it likely to have learned
well i think um the main lesson is that
china will have plans military plans on
the shelf for taking taiwan and they
will have undoubtedly experimented with
some of those elements to train their
forces and also to see how they can
train in the joint environment airland
and maritime complicated environment
training together in addition though
they will have also seen how taiwan has
reacted to to their provocation because
inevitably that will adapt how china's
plans evolve but they've also tellingly
been seeing what the west can do and uh
most of the west has really not been
involved in it at all and what that
shows is that there is no real effective
military defense for taiwan against the
massive military might of china the only
other option of course is that they look
to international help for their um
the challenge there is that uh bluntly
ukraine as an independent country when
that was invaded by russia nato and the
u.s was really reluctant to get involved
taiwan is not recognized as an
independent country it's very close to
china and as a result it seems highly
unlikely that the west would come to the
aid it's very difficult to conclude
through all of this that china won't
feel even more emboldened by the results
and the fallout from this exercise
so that's very crucial actually what
you've just said because if the west is
unwilling to intervene militarily at
least that is is it likely then that
taiwan will be invaded well i think the
military prognosis it was a purely
military uh question the answer is it
looks pretty bleak taiwan though and
ukraine are not the only parts of the
world where there are disagreements
about historical ownership of land or
whatever territorial disputes most of
those are resolved or is kept at bay by
diplomacy using force as the
force of last resort um because if you
use military to solve these problems
there needs to be consequences to that
for example putin's russia has invaded
ukraine it has had some tactical
victories by taking some land but
strategically its forces have been shown
to be pretty woeful it's not established
russia greatness there are huge economic
sanctions as a result and he hasn't
stopped the expansion of nato tactical
success strategic failure
what are the consequences for china if
they were to use their military might to
take um to take taiwan or elsewhere and
if there are those consequences how do
you dissuade them from acting if you
ignore it
the challenges we did with crimea in
2014 the consequences are grave we
mustn't let history repeat itself